We have x plus 1 equals plus or minus the square root of 13 over 3. Now, you may
we wondering why it doesn't look like I took the positive and negative versions
of the square root of the left side of the equation. But with this equation
right here, we're actually covering all of our possible solutions for x. Here's
why. We know that if we have a square root of a number, and we make that
negative. Then that's just equal to negative 1 times the square root of that
number. The negative version of this square root effects would then be negative
1 times that. Which is negative x minus 1. Let's say that we had this in an
equation as well, with the same thing on the right side. They're more
effectively taking care of the plus and minus versions of the left root. This is
going to give us four different equations, which are these four equations right
here. However, we need to notice something special about these equations. If we
take this equation, negative x minus 1 equals negative root 13 over 3, and we
divide both sides by negative 1. We end up with x plus 1 equals the root of 13
over 3, which is just this equation up here. That means that one of our
equations in the second pair is the same as an equation in the first pair. Now
if we do the same thing for these 2 equations. The 2 we haven't touched on yet.
We'd find that they are equivalent as well. So if we take the positive and
negative square roots of both sides of the equation, So it saves us some time to
only put the plus or minus in front of 1 side of the equation. And just take the
positive square root of the other side. Or the negative 1 if you prefer that.